Carlos Felipe Arturo Jorge Windsor nació
el 14 de noviembre de 1948 en el Palacio
de buckingham El mayor de los cuatro
hijos de la Reina Isabel II y el
príncipe Felipe
tenía tres años cuando su madre se
convirtió en reina en 1952
[Música]
y a los 20 fue Coronado como príncipe de
gales
[Música]
los amores del monarca han sido motivo
de polémica Carlos y Camila Parker se
habían conocido en 1970 pero mientras él
estaba en la Marina Camila se casó con
Andrew Parker bowles
[Música]
Carlos contrajo matrimonio en 1981 con
Lady di catalogado como el evento
televisivo más visto en la historia de
la humanidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
una turbulenta historia que terminó
cuando Carlos admitió en 1994 que tuvo
una relación extramatrimonial con Camila
Parker
un hecho que le costó mucho a la realeza
británica especialmente después de que
la llamada princesa del pueblo muriera
en un accidente automovilístico en París
en 1997
pero la historia de amor continuó en
2005 Carlos y Camila se casaron
convirtiéndose en la Duquesa de cornoal
[Aplausos]
el también llamado Rey de las flores por
su devoción a la botánica ha defendido a
lo largo de su vida temas
medioambientales como la creación de una
organización que promueve la
alimentación ecológica recientemente
destacó la importancia de China para
resolver el cambio climático un tema que
le podría ayudar a aumentar su
popularidad especialmente entre los
jóvenes
Durante los últimos años Carlos fue
asumiendo numerosas funciones
monárquicas mientras la salud de la
reina desmejoraba
ahora se ha visto su esfuerzo por
mostrarse más cercano y cálido al
público mientras ASUME su rol como el
nuevo jefe de estado británico y cabeza
de la iglesia anglicana
[Aplausos]